>> WELCOME BACK TO LAS VEGAS.
NOW WE ARE CAVING IN TO THE 3
I'S S CHAMPIONSHIP TOURNAMENT.
>> TOMORROW AT THE ORLEANS
ARENA AND SKATER PRO SKATER TJ
HIM THINK OF TEAM LECLAIRE AND
3 I THEO EJ JOHNSTON GUYS ARE
HERE TO GET US UP WE'RE
EXCITED TO WRAP UP BY SAYING
LOOK GOOD MY WAY RIGHT NOW
YOU'RE WEARING TEAM ON THE
LLOW TEAM THEY HAVE BEEN UP
THE TOP TEAM IN THE LEAGUE
THIS YEAR ON A NIGHTLY. BUT HE
JAYS TEAM IS PROBABLY HAS
SOMETHING TO SAY ABOUT I SAW
YOUR FACE GET A LITTLE HELEATED
WHEN HE MENTION I HAVE MY TEAM
IS.
>> I MEAN THEY'VE WON 5, 5,
OUT OF THEOF WEEKEND SO. BUT
TOMORROW'S A NEW DAY AND A
CHANCE TO KNOCK HIM THE
PEDESTAL THEY'VE BEEN ON LIKE
THAT I LIKE THAT ATTITUDE EVEN T
THOUGH THEY'RE MY TEAM HE $1 SC
SATURDAY, 1PM AT
BUT OKAY, SO TELL US YOU KNOW
YOU BROUGHT THIS HERE IN JUNE
YOU GUYS ARE HERE TO TELL US
ABOUT THE ANNOUNCEMENT OF THE
TOURNAMENT.
>> AND WHAT HAS HAPPENED SINCE
THEN AND THAT SO WE LOVE VEGAS
AS SPORTS MARKETING HOCKEY
TIMES BOOK AND WE STARTED WITH
WEEK ONE WE'RE GOING TO FINISH
OUR CHAMPIONSHIPS.
>> WE KICKED OFF HERFFE AND THI
IS THE 9TH WEEK WE'VE GOT OUR
TOP 4 TEAMS COMPETING FOR
MILLION DOLLAR PRIZE IT IS A
VERY BIG DEAL YELLING AT 7
GUYS ON THE TEAM, SO THEY'RE
SPLITTING UP THAT MONEY
THEMSELVES. IT'S GOING TO BE
INCREDIBLY THE HOCKEYHO HAS BEE
GETTING BEINTTER AND  BETT ER
MO RE M ORE  INTE NSE AS I ASSO
ANOTHER HEINTERVIEW RVEARLIER IE
THAT'S A LITTA LE SLASHESLS D D
ME SKIRMISHES ON THE ICE NOW
SEEN SOME GREAT NOW THAT
YOU'VE GOT YOU KNOW FEW
DUST-UPS AND I I PERSONALLY
LOVE THAT THE FANS LOVE IT YOU
KNOW TJ HAS BEEN ONE OF OUR
OUR BEOUST OUPLAYOUERS OUOUOUOU
OUSCOUORINOUG OUOUOUOUSOMEOU UNU
OUGOALOUS FOOUR USOU ALLOU SEAOU
OUOKAYOU TOOUDAY OUSO YOOUUR OU
OUTOOUMORROUOW. OUOUOUOUOUOUOUO
WHAT WHAT'S GOING THROUGH YOUR O
MIND RIGHT NOW TIGER TO BE
AWESOME TO BE PRETTY NERVOUS.
I FORTUNE OF AND DIFFERENT
LEAGUES THROUGHOUT MY CAREER
BUT.
>> I'VE NEVER PLAYED FOR THIS
MOMENT FOR ONE CITING ITS
GOING TO EXTREMELY HOPE THEIR
TEAM CAN COME OUT ON TOP,
YOU'RE GOING TO SEE SOME LIKE
YOU JUST SAID BLOCKING SOME
COUPLE SLUSH HERE AND THERE
IT'S LITTLE MORE PHYSICAL HAS
BEEN THE FIRST 8 WEEKS BUT
IT'S GOING TO EXCITING IT'S
GOING TO BE AND MY TEAM COMES
OUT ON HOPEFULLY YOU SAID A
MILLION DOLLARS WERE PLANNED
FOR MILLION WHAT WOULD YOU DO
IF YOU WON WITH ME.
>> BE ONE OF OLDER GUYS IN THE
GROUP I PROBABLY WOULD TAKE
THE FAMILY ON A A NICE
VACATION, ESPECIALLY MY WIFE,
YOU KNOW IT'S BEEN A
CHALLENGING SUMMER BEING GONE
EVERY SATURDAY IT'S BEEN FUN,
IT'S BEEN EXCITING IF YOU GET
THE CHANCE I WOULD TAKE THEM A
NICE VACATION I LOVE THAT I
LOVE NOT NOT REFER BE PLAYING
AGAINST YOU WOULD NOT ROOTING
FOR YOU TODAY,TO NOT YOU TO TEL
EVERYBODY HOW THEY CAN COME
JOIN YOU GUYS AND SUPPORT YOU
ON THE ICE TOMORROW SO OUR ON
AT 1 O'CLOCK LOCAL TIME. BUT
WE ALSO CAN GET TICKETS AT 3
ICE BUT DOT COM AND WE'RE YOU
PLANT THE ORLEANS ARENA SEE
CAN COME DOWN OR GO ONLINE AND
CHECK US OUT IT'S GOING TO BE
FANTASTIC. IT'S 2 HOURS OF
JUST HAIR ON FIRE GRABBED ME
HOCKEY IT'S GOING TO BE
ELECTRIC.
>> I LOVE IT ALL RIGHT TJ TJ
GOOD LUCK TOMORROW HAVE FUN
RIPA INFORMATION ONE MORE TIME
FOR EVERYBODY AT
4 TEAMS FIGHTING TO